il ya quelques jours est sorti ce
smartphone là ce smartphone là c'est le
finepix trois pros de au pot il ya plein
de produits qui sont sortis au pot
notamment le finepix 3d ou dans quelque
chose et vous parlez vous donner mon
retour définitif sur le finepix trois
pros en attendant je veux qu'on parle un
petit peu de la version logicielle parce
qu'avoir un smartphone c'est bien la
rambo smartphones c'est très chouette
faire de belles photos mais savoir ce
qu'on peut faire avec d'un point de vue
logiciel c'est encore mieux c'est la
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui on va
se concentrer je vous donnais pas moins
de monde comme un joli noté 18 astuces
18 astuces pour bien utiliser color os
dopo et vous allez voir que l'on est ce
c'est vraiment pas mal mais vraiment pas
super intéressant pas vous allez voir je
peux vous montrer
[Musique]
on va commencer déjà ici partout côté
personnalisation parce que ça c'est
vraiment un truc que je te super super
super intéressant et notamment son le
always-on display vous avez différentes
petit motif et vous pouvez même venir
créer le vôtre pour créer le vôtre
suffit de créer sur le petit plus ici
vous allez retrouver motifs
personnalisés
là vous choisissez un peu parmi les
couleurs prédéfinis pourrait même dire
vous même
regardez créer votre pas termes de
couleurs ensuite vous venez ici et là
vous venez dessiner des petites choses
voyez sur le côté c'est vraiment où
calais le faire en fonction de vos
mouvements alors bien évidemment vous
êtes guidé plus plus plus plus par le
logiciel pourrait changer de couleur
dans l'idée vraiment de la
personnalisation c'est vachement bien et
vient modifier aussi la couleur du texte
et il va vous avez terminé comme
convient vous faites appliquer et où
vous retrouverez avec votre motif
directement sur leurs loisirs display et
ça c'est très très chouette puisque dans
la personnalisation il ya pas mal
d'options directement ici chez au pôle
est-il d'icônes ça change de forme
d'icônes en fait vous le voyez héros
comme ça que vous avez vraiment la forme
d'icônes que vous voulez si vous voulez
click'n intégré soit plus ou moins de
rendre plus ou moins peut-il vous pouvez
venir module est directement ici pareil
pour style d'en prendre pour votre
capteur d'empreinte digitale au niveau
de la taille de police au niveau de la
police et même sur l'éclairage des bords
que vous allez retrouver sur le côté ici
depuis vos paramètres ce synode
fonctionne et et qui est super
intéressante il faut vous alliez dans
l'outil confort vous allez dans gestes
et mouvements et dans geste sur écran
est un et là bien évidemment vous me
l'activité pas mal de petites options
qui sont super sympas
par exemple vous pouvez toucher deux
fois l'écran pour allumer l'écran hop là
par exemple il est instable deux fois
sam l'allument
je peux dessiner un rond pour ouvrir à
l'appareil photo ob parijs décines
aurons
samour l'appareil photo c'est de tirer
confié qu'ils sont super super sympa je
peux dessiner un v pour activer la
torche le v de la victoire
hop là la torche est allumé on peut
également dire contrôler la musique avec
deux doigts je fais plaît aux morceaux
suivants morceau précédent et après je
vais te dire a ajouté mes propres gestes
par exemple je peux me dire qu'un
glisser vers le haut ça me permettra de
déverrouiller c'est vrai train d'atteler
ou de masquer une application enfin il
ya une petite possibilité à notre qui
marche bien chez opodo c'est la capture
d'écran trois doigts du haut vers le bas
je re cliquer dessus je me fais un
défilement je vais jusqu'en bas jusqu'en
bas jusqu'en bas donc là hop je clique
et là ça ne crée une capture d'écran de
toute ma page
donc si je vais enregistrer un article
et je lui lire après une fois de plus
bas c'est très pratique et un autre truc
qui est assez sympa on va aller se
mettre sur un site étranger et moi ce
que je veux c'est comprendre un peu ce
qu'il ya parce que je suis très très
mauvais en anglais je me fais une
capture d'écran en trois doigts hop j'ai
ma capture ici et là je clique sur
traduit sais pas si vous le voyez bien
up traduire et la voyait google lance
j'ai une traduction mon texte mais ça
c'est vraiment pratique
ou alors ce que vous faites en des temps
votre page et bien vous venez glisser
comme ça c'est le côté programme petit
menu latéral dans lequel vous allez
retrouver une partie traduction vous
clic et hop
google health de la même manière et là
ça vous traduit votre page dont vous
avez deux façons soit par la capture
d'écran soit comme ça si vous voulez
faire du multitâche pour les trois
devoirs vous partez du bas vers le haut
up
choisissez ensuite la deuxième
application que vous souhaitez ouvrir
avec jenson et moi par exemple
whatsapp tu peux venir et partir en
dessous de la taille de mes fenêtres ça
c'est assez pratique
il ya un autre qui est pas mal et qui a
fait mal a ici pour avoir plusieurs
comptes qui coexistent au sein du même
smartphone par exemple ici l'art a déjà
cliquez en haut je vais me retrouver
avec plusieurs comptes j'ai mon compte
perso j'ai mon compte professionnel il
ya un compte invité
si je veux aller sur le compte pro par
exemple ap la garder je viens switcher
comme sa permutation de compte je viens
déverrouiller avec hop là une autre
empreinte digitale et j'arrive sur mon
deuxième compte ça c'est sympa et de la
même manière pour le compte invité je
viens une fois de plus cliquez ici je
clique sur mon compte invité est ce que
je peut permuter
oui et là j'arrive dans un autre espace
voyages absolument aucune application de
tout ce que j'avais installé sur mon
compte perso donc je peux vraiment venir
différencier toutes les applications
jeux installés entre d'un côté le pronom
côté le perso de côté un compte invité
si ça m'intéresse
il ya peu qui est vachement intéressant
au niveau confidentialité sur le
smartphone de au pot vous venez cliquez
ici au niveau de vos paramètres vous
allez dans confidentialité vous allez
d'en masquer les applis
il faut avoir un petit code moi j'ai mon
code et vous choisissez les applications
vous souhaitez masqué alors moi j'ai
masquer un podcast je peux venir à
masquer une autre par exemple
l'application instagram et bien ces
applications la up quand je sors voyez
elles sont plus du tout visible
instagram n'est pas là elle est planqué
pour la retrouver c'est facile vous avez
dans votre application de téléphone et
vous devez taper un code secret que vous
avez définies moi mon code secret c'est
diez 000 diez ça c'est uniquement un
exemple et là je retrouve mes applis
masquer que son instagram et google
podcast donc pouvait masquer ce que vous
voulez plan qu'est ce que vous voulez
pour la raison vous voulez ça ne me
regarde pas mais en tout cas si vous
pouvez le faire via vous pouvez faire
autres paquets vachement intéressant au
niveau de la sécurité vous avez une
faute plus dans vos paramètres ici vous
voulez chercher sécurité et là vous
venez dans sos d'urgence juste ici cette
fonction servira à venir vous protéger
si par exemple vous êtes agressé dans la
rue si par exemple eh bien vous avez un
accident pour tous les problèmes que
vous pouvez rencontrer ici notamment et
convenir a fait cinq fois sur le bouton
d'alimentation pour sabine passer un
appel de rares vous avez vos différents
numéros d'urgence je choisis le contact
d'urgence ça peut être un ami ça peut
être la police ça peut être n'importe
qui je vais ajouter directement ici en
fait ce qui se passe ça me permettra
d'appeler automatiquement le numéro des
services d'urgence
quand je vois puis cinq fois sur le
bouton d'alimentation au bout de trois
secondes ça va venir appelé directement
le service d'urgence donc là je choisis
ici entre numéro d'urgence le 112 sont
anania et bien évidemment le numéro que
j'aurai choisi bon et si j'en ai pas
mangé avec le 112 par exemple je vais
émettre un avertissement sonore avant de
numéroter si par exemple j'appuie cinq
fois par a par erreur que ça ne devienne
pas le faire et puis je peux également
envoyé un message automatique de sos
joindre une photo de l'environnement qui
sera prise à la à l'aide du capteur
avant et arrière donc je vais exactement
ce qui se passe dans la mesure où c'est
visible depuis mon smartphone est ce que
j'en ai également un enregistrement
audio de cinq secondes donc la personne
ne savait ce contact et aura accès à ma
géolocalisation saura où je suis donc ça
c'est extrêmement sécurisé en astuces
que son super intéressante sur mon
smartphone de hope au niveau du mode
sombre je viens choisir et en fait j'ai
accès à plusieurs modes sombre g soit un
moteur amélioré c'est sur lequel je suis
j'ai un vote sont un moyen qui est un
peu moins son nom en fait et j'aime son
doux où je vais être sur un grigri
légèrement cassée alors le stock à
savoir ici c'est que comme sur le lait
d'ici à pixels noirs et un pixel est un
don dès que je viens moduler et que je
vous retrouve pas sur quelque chose de
tout noir notamment aussi sur quelque
chose de grille et bien venir consommer
au niveau de la batterie puisque malaise
va être allumées donc bon l'optimisation
complète s'est vraiment améliorée mais
si vous souhaitez tout un module est
moss ont aidé à garder vous pouvez le
faire ça c'est rigolo j'avais jamais vu
encore autre astuce qui est intéressante
mais dans outils confort et vous avez
dans capture vidéo de l'écran là vous
allez faire une capture
si vous souhaitez vous filmez pour une
partie du guide libyen vous avez pas mal
d'options qui sont super intéressante
enregistrer le son du système vous
pouvez également enregistrer le son du
micro
choisissez votre résolution d'affichage
de maître par exemple ou en 1080p votre
fréquence d'image peut mettre en
dynamique
le format de codage vidéo si je veux
être en h 264 h 263 et puis également
utiliser l'appareil photo avant pour
venir me filmer lorsque je vais jouer à
quelque chose par exemple
donc vous avez toutes ces petites robes
sur laquelle sont super intéressante et
je vous dis une fois de plus pour les
gamer ça c'est pas mal du tout autre
astuce pendant smartphones de au pot je
vais dans outils confort et je vais dans
lancement rapide alors que ça me
permettra lancement rapide et bien voyez
c'est de venir ouvrir des applications
très facilement il faisait déverrouiller
mon doigt avec son capteur d'empreintes
digitales
je montre smartphone est un jeu pose
mendois gelais s'appuyer et hop
j'ai mon petit lancement rapide je
choisi l'application que je n'ai
orwellien facebook music ou l'assistant
alors là j'en ai trois au choix mais ce
peut venir complètement les
personnaliser quand je suis ici il
suffit d'aller sur modifier comme
l'ajouté l'agenda peuvent rajouter
l'appareil photo je peux en supprimer
par exemple le supprimer l'assistant et
je sais pas moi qu'est-ce que je
pourrais vouloir mettre ici ben attia
instagram claque mais j'ai également
aussi des fonctions avec la sncf par
exemple le souvenir de discuter avec
l'assistant sur spotify bien je peux
lancer une de mes playlists vous allez
voir je mourrai ici quelques jours le
tourneau mis vraiment sympa sur ce
finepix 3 promet si je veux aller encore
plus loin si j'arrive tout à la fin de
niveau de ma batterie est bien joué dans
les paramètres jeunes en batterie et je
peux venir activé mode super économies
d'énergie comme et si tout va être noir
se sont rendus cran l'aide d'un pixel
morata pixels est allongée à économiser
au niveau de mon énergie pour tous les
accès uniquement à six applications que
je peux venir choisir directement et
personnalisées alors moi je veux
vraiment rester dans l'efficace
j'appelle je reçois un message j'ai
netflix si je regarde d'un petit film
mais ça va forcément être qu'avec le
plus économe et si je veux je peux
spotify j'écoute de la musique / garder
email et puisque ma d un peu sur
instagram pour rester en contact
autre astuce sur mon smartphone de hope
aussi par exemple j'ai une photo que je
veux rendre privé je veux pas que tout
le monde voit et bien je vais dans photo
jocelyn riendeau qu'est ce que j'ai
comme faut tout âge et celle là par
exemple mais cette photo là elle
extrêmement important de personnes la
voix est bien ce que je fais c'est que
je viens là sélectionnés en restant
appuyé dessus et juste en bas là
d ici j'ai une option qui s'appelle
rendre privé hop elle est planqué et
maintenant cette photo vous ne la voyez
plus elle n'est plus là elle est dans
mon coffre fort et quand je veux avoir
accès à mon coffre fort je fais un appui
long en haut dans le menu il va me
demander de mettre mon empreinte
digitale up et j'ai accès aux photos que
j'ai planqué
côté multi tâche est aussi un point que
vous est pas montré quel super
intéressant par exemple venir choisir je
sais pas moi l'application photos je
clique ici sur les petits points en jeu
peut venir faire ce qu'ils appellent une
fenêtre flottante donc je vais retrouver
ici ma petite fenêtre avec mes
différentes photos il peut même venir
hop là je reste appuyé je vais la mettre
là j'espère maintenant beaucoup plus
petite si par exemple je veux mettre ça
dans un coin et que je veux aller par
exemple ouvrir une autre application en
est flic su nous regarder un film
pendant ce temps mais de jeter un petit
coup d'oeil là dessus et bien voyez je
peux autre astuce qui est super cool
quand je veux venir un film et et que je
veux par exemple que mon sujet soit
suivi et bien tu vas voir ce qu'on
appelle le focus tracking je prends un
petit accessoire
j'ai ça je viens double cliquer dessus
il voit mon objet je déplace mon objet
et je vois que j'ai luron qui le suit
donc mon personnage va être complètement
suivi tout ça c'est pas mal pour avoir
toujours la netteté dans tout ce que
vous allez venir filmer voyez donc ça
voyez on n'est pas hollywood mais en
tout cas on se rapproche doucement sur
la partie photo il ya notre note que je
trouve aussi super super sympa vous
venez par exemple choisir une photo
keystone attire la prendre celle là là
je me dis ah ah mince chez cette espèce
de gros trucs en plein milieu de la
photo qui est très très moche et je
voudrais le supprimer en fait je peux je
clique sur modifier ici je vais dans
effaceur je commence par faire le tour
et sélectionner tout ce que je veux
supprimer et ensuite je vis une gomme et
partout à l'intérieur
la up et calculs et ensuite il supprime
et ça c'est vachement bien
j'ai d'autres options car si vous êtes
au niveau de core os pour les photos eh
bien regardez par exemple au niveau des
dents voyez la petite que note
et bien je peux venir complètement les
blanchir de façon complètement
artificiel je viens là je vais tout au
bout je vais dans embellir et d'embellir
je vais là et j'ai blanchir les dents en
or la voyez j'ai mes petites dents eh
bien je la pousse et ça à fond à fond et
là regardez le sourire ultra bright est
ce que là on se croirait pas passer par
un cabinet dentaire
donc ça c'est la photo retouchée et ça
c'est la vraie photo regardez la
différence allait quand même énorme
une astuce que j'aime beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup sur corot est si vous voulez
avoir un fond d'écran qui est
complètement personnalisé vous aide
personnalisation fonds d'écran et dans
fond d'écran vous venez ce regard est
tout en aidant galerie vous devez
choisir une photo que vous voulez
utiliser pour les codes couleurs et
uniquement les codes couleurs qu'est-ce
que j'ai moins sympa au niveau des codes
couleurs belges et salah ce rouge là le
stop vue au microscope ça donne ça donc
moi je veux choisir sa cette couleur là
ça ça m'intéresse
eh bien je n'appuie pas sur appliquer
chapuis juste au dessus la regarder ici
ça me calcule la colorimétrie et ça me
propose des motifs en fonction de la
couleur que que ça extrait de la faute
au regard des gens qui sont super sympas
hyper originaux hop là je me mets
définir comme fond d'écran
donc ça va vous d'aller beaucoup plus
loin au niveau de la personnalisation
sur le smartphone de au pot et ça c'est
très très chouette
voilà pour ces astuces concernant coloré
la bonne manière à laquelle vous
préférez est-ce que vous avez une
préférence sur la partie photo sur la
partie double vie je passerai peut dire
ça comme ça
professionnel familial c'est un peu
l'idée c'est vraiment là dessus que je
l'entends qu'est ce qui vous plaît plus
qu'est-ce qui vous interpellent est-ce
que vous reconnaissiez et si vous avez
déjà un smartphone de au point qu on ne
s est ce qu'il ya une astuce que je n'ai
pas mentionné que vous connaissez qui
serait intéressant est comprise histoire
de marquer moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire quand on se retrouve très
vite pour continuer bien évidemment par
les tacles surtout pour vous donner mon
retour ce smartphone là qu'il joue du
tout de suite qui est super intéressant
mais vraiment super intéressant il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire beaucoup
voilà nous avions pris le temps pascal
bodjona raconté et ça c'est très
chouette
les bijoux des coeurs à bientôt chaos